bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Boris ballot bonsoir et merci
d'être là d'être le président du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée nationale
depuis un an tout juste c'est donc
l'heure de faire votre bilan 31 députés
socialistes au sein de la nuque pas mal
de boulot sur le fond il faut le
reconnaître mais avec quel victoire
politique à l'arrivée on en parlera
votre partie est bien secoué en interne
par un courant qui s'ensurge contre
cette alliance avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon
on en parlera aussi vous faites liste à
part aux européennes deuxième partie
rendez-vous tout à l'heure mais on
commence ce soir par la crise au Journal
du Dimanche la nomination de Geoffroy
Lejeune un proche d'Eric Zemmour à la
direction de la rédaction de la de la
société de la direction du JDD
pardonnez-moi a suscité un tollé les
journalistes sont en grève soutenus par
un très grand nombre de personnalités
notamment du monde politique la crise
s'invite dans l'hémicie quatre questions
au Gouvernement aujourd'hui le système
Bolloré qui contrôle le vous aider et
pointer du doigt alors que faire il y
a-t-il de quoi s'alarmer pour notre
démocratie et puis comment garantir la
liberté de la presse et l'indépendance
de l'information dans notre pays c'est
un débat important et nous l'aurons dans
un instant avec mes invités avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur
parties prises d'embourbons Express ce
soir se déjeuner presque secret de
Nicolas Sarkozy avec une poignée de
députés de la majorité voilà pour le
programme vous me suivez Boris Balou et
bien ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est un propriétaire pas comme les
autres une nouvelle fois la main mise de
Vincent Bolloré sur les médias suscitent
une très vive émotion et cette fois
c'est la nomination à la tête du JDD de
Geoffroy Lejeune l'ancien directeur de
valeurs actuelles qui ne passent pas le
journal d'Arnaud Lagardère sous le
contrôle du groupe Vivendi de Vincent
Bolloré n'est pas sorti ce dimanche et
pas moins de 4 questions au Gouvernement
sur le sujet cet après-midi parce qu'il
y en a des questions qui se posent dans
cette affaire bonsoir Christophe Marion
et merci d'être là vous êtes député
renaissance du Loir-et-Cher vous allez
signer la tribune de soutien au JTD qui
est paru dans Le Monde le ministre
Olivier Véran qui est responsable du
renouveau démocratique a pris la parole
et à inviter les députés à se saisir du
sujet et à même revoir le cadre légal
vous nous direz ce que vous proposez
bonsoir Fabien et Philippot bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes député les
républicains de Moselle bonsoir
Valentine auberti bonsoir ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes journaliste à
Mediapart responsable du pôle vidéo à
l'air libre avec luckermann du
documentaire mediacras qui a tué le
débat public c'était en salle il y a un
an au cinéma sur ces milliardaires qui
concentrent la quasi-totalité des médias
privés au service de leurs intérêts
bonsoir enfin Alexis lévrier et merci
d'être là vous êtes chercheur au Celsa
spécialiste de l'histoire du journalisme
moteur de Jupiter et Mercure le pouvoir
présidentiel face à la presse c'était
aux éditions du Petit Matin Boris Vallot
vous aussi vous avez signé cette tribune
de soutien aux JDD dans le monde vous
nous direz pourquoi on va commencer par
planter le décor que que vit exactement
le JDD depuis quelques jours il a deux
secondes c'est le chrono de Blacko tout
de suite
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir Myriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
expliquez-nous alors vous êtes peut-être
rendu compte que ce weekend il n'y avait
pas de JD dans le kiosque et pour cause
99% de la rédaction est en grève pour
protester contre donc la domination
Geoffroy Lejeune à la tête du journal
alors ce qui inquiète la rédaction c'est
que Geoffroy Lejeune est un grand fan
d'Éric Zemmour dès 2015 il avait
d'ailleurs écrit un roman pour imaginer
que Zemmour serait un jour élu président
et puis quand il a été nommé la
direction de Valeurs Actuelles vous
allez voir qu'il a régulièrement fait
des une pour assurer la promotion de son
chouchou grâce à leurs actuelles voyez
il ne cachait pas c'est préférences mais
ça dépasse malgré tout le cadre du JDD
parce que on se rend compte que
quasiment la totalité des rédactions des
grands médias de ce pays ont apporté
leur soutien à la rédaction du JDD ça va
de l'humanité au Figaro de Télérama et
TF1 je vous ai pris un exemple vous
voyez on a vu le même texte la même
tribune paraître dans Les Echos donc
propriété du milliardaire Bernard
Arnault et aussi dans Mediapart qui
pourfend le capitalisme
dès qu'il en a euh l'occasion il y a
vraiment quelque chose de très
professionnel toute la profession s'est
mobilisée alors pour la décision de
nommer Geoffroy Lejeune à la tête de
l'heure actuelle officiellement c'est
Arnaud Lagardère et qui a pris cette
décision et d'ailleurs ce matin il
voulait rassurant en disant
rassurez-vous je vous garantis Geoffroy
le jeune ne fera pas la promo de Zemmour
dans le JDD bon en fait ça rassure pas
grand monde évidemment puisque le groupe
Lagardère a été racheté par Vincent
Bolloré et on sait bien que d'ores et
déjà c'est lui qui tire les ficelles
c'est ça qui inquiète parce que à chaque
fois que Bolloré a pris possession d'un
média c'est toujours un peu le même
schéma il est toujours entré en conflit
avec la rédaction pour imposer sa ligne
édictoriale donc voyez le monde a tenu
la chronique de ces différentes prises
de pouvoir dans les journaux ça a
commencé à iiler une grève d'un mois qui
n'a pas empêché la rédaction de perdre
ce bras de fer la chaîne est devenue
cnews depuis ça a été le cas Europe 1 ou
les salariés sont mis en grève mais là
aussi la rédaction a été remodelée à la
manière de Bolloré pareil pour Paris
Match donc forcément quand on voit que
c'est maintenant le cas du JDD bien et
bien pas très bonne augure pour les
journalistes du JDD donc là où la faire
après une tournure plus politique c'est
quand la ministre de la Culture est
intervenue dans le débat en publiant ce
tweet ou elle posait une question elle
s'alarmer on se demandant ce qui malgré
tout cette nomination que je ferai le
jeune n'était pas menace pour les
valeurs républicaines alors ça pose la
question est-ce que c'est le rôle d'une
ministre d'aller critiquer la nomination
de tel ou telle journaliste dans un
magazine la réponse du Front national
c'était tout à l'heure aux questions
gouvernement elle s'appelle Caroline
Parmentier que la ministre de la Culture
comme des certificats de valeurs
républicaines aux journaux français et
particulièrement inquiétant pour la
démocratie bon alors la ministre de la
Culture n'était pas là pour répondre
heureusement Olivier Béran lui il est
toujours prêt à répondre on l'écoute mes
oreilles enseignées parce que madame la
députée jusqu'à il y a 15 jours votre
parti politique dirigé par votre
président de groupe Madame Le Pen
censurer boycotter une chaîne
d'information BFM TV parce que laver
loutre qui danse de faire un choix
éditorial qui consistait à recruter un
journaliste de l'émission quotidien ça
c'est pour la bataille politique cet
après-midi mais après tout et Vincent
Bolloré dans cette situation finalement
qu'est-ce qu'il dit alors il se trouve
qu'il s'était expliqué devant une
commission du Sénat c'était au début de
l'année dernière justement on
s'inquiétait à l'idée qu'il construisent
un empire médiatique pour imposer ses
idées donc première partie de sa défense
en disant mais moi je suis tout petit je
suis pour quel empire vous parlez donc
il parle des différents titres qu'il
arragent qu'il a racheté en disant le
Journal du Dimanche et le 9e journal du
7e jour comme on dit par image de 12e
Hebdo cnews c'est jamais que la 11e
chaîne de télé et Europe 1 le 10e donc
c'est un argument pour dire qu'il ne
menace pas le pluralisme avec des médias
qui sont plutôt qui ne sont pas leaders
après quand on lui a fait le reproche de
avoir embauché Zemmour pour imposer ses
idées en 2019 je lui dis pas du tout
c'est pas pour mes idées c'est
simplement économiques ce n'est pas
cnews qui a fait le succès de Zemmour
c'est Zemmour qui a fait le succès de
news on écoute quant à Zemmour
pardonnez-moi mais il est publié des
livres à des centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires bien avant qu'il ne
reviennent sur cnews je vous rappelle
qu'il est sur le Figaro je vous rappelle
qu'il est sur la 6 et comme par hasard
c'est quand il est sur cnews que ça va
mon problème
bon c'est bon je vous laisse débattre
juste une question c'est sûr que dans un
pays où les candidats dit d'extrême
droite ont fait 30% au premier tour à la
présidentielle je sais bien que ça fait
pas plaisir mais est-ce que c'est
anormal que ces idées soient présentées
dans la presse à vous d'en débattre
merci beaucoup Stéphane je commence avec
vous Christophe Marion vous avez signé
cette tribune Geoffroy le jeune
directeur de la rédaction du GD pour
vous ça veut dire quoi précisément
est-ce que ça veut dire pour vous que le
JDD va devenir un titre d'extrême droite
la crainte elle est réelle quand on voit
ce qu'est devenu au fil du temps
va leurs actuelles était quand même un
journal condamné pour pour racisme pour
propagation d'idées d'idées vraiment
d'extrême droite je crois qu'on peut
nous je le précise qui est élu député
ici à l'Assemblée nationale mais ce
qu'on avait représenté avec une chaîne
au cou en esclave exactement et donc on
peut s'inquiéter légitimement se poser
la question de savoir quelle va être à
présent ligne éditoriale du JDD qui ne
s'est jamais inscrit dans cette histoire
jusqu'à présent donc je crois qu'en
effet on peut légitimement s'offusquer
ou en tous les cas comprendre
la réaction de la rédaction aujourd'hui
98% du personnel est en grève ce qui est
quand même enfin moi j'arrive dans un
endroit j'ai 98% de mon personnel qui se
met en grève immédiatement ça
m'interroge quand même personnellement
très bien dit c'est pas n'importe quel
journal Le Journal du Dimanche d'abord
et oui d'une position assez dominante et
elle parisien on va pas commencer à
voilà à dire qu'il est il est seul mais
tout de même les journalistes disent la
SDJ la société des journalistes c'est
que c'est complètement en contradiction
avec les valeurs de journal que de
nommer Geoffroy Lejeune il y a d'autres
titres le monde par exemple les échos
aussi qui ont un droit de veto ils l'ont
négocié avec leur actionnaire il faut
que 60% des journalistes approuvent la
nomination par l'actionnaire du
directeur de la rédaction est-ce que
c'est pas une une bonne idée
démocratique pour que justement ceux qui
font le journal soit on adéquation avec
ce qui les dirige ce que je trouve
étrange c'est que quand on parle de
pluralisme des médias souvent on a le
pluralisme à sens unique si ça avait été
une personnalité plutôt à gauche qui
avait été nommé à la tête du JDD on
aurait sans doute pas eu le débat qu'on
a là la vérité c'est que c'est un média
privé alors vous en avez évoqué d'autres
le monde Le Figaro qui ont leur histoire
avec leur rédaction qui ont des modes de
fonctionnement qui leur sont qui leur
sont propres maintenant faire croire que
d'un coup parce que il y a cette
nomination là le pluralisme des médias
serait remis en cause en France déjà des
groupes privés il y en a une multitude
et les chiffres l'ont montré peut-être
sans doute plus dominant que celui
d'Europe un cnews et du et du JDD mais
ensuite quand on parle de pluralisme il
y a une chose qu'il ne faut pas qu'il ne
faut pas oublier c'est qu'aujourd'hui et
bien près d'un Français sur deux plus de
40%, sa forme via les réseaux sociaux
quand on descend chez les jeunes c'est
quasiment les 2/3 donc vous voyez on
peut avoir vos données parce que selon
vous les médias actuels ne sont pas
représentatifs suffisamment du débat
public dans son entièreté c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont sur les réseaux sociaux vous
croyez alors il y a deux choses
effectivement à un moment donné est-ce
que le champ média le champ médiatique
et
vraiment révélateur des positions de
chacun ça c'est une chose mais surtout
parce que les modes de consommation de
l'information avec l'immédiateté avec
des formats très très courts évoluent
évoluent et c'est ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut prendre en compte donc vous n'êtes
pas inquiez-vous la nomination de
Geoffre le jeune
c'est pas le pluralisme en France c'est
la qualité de l'information qui est
délivrée aux Français à partir du moment
où ils sont abreuvés de réseaux sociaux
ou pour le coup on n'a pas forcément des
professionnels et on a des gens qui
peuvent dire énormément de choses qui ne
sont pas vérifiées qui se répandent
comme des traînés de poudre c'est
surtout là-dessus qu'on devrait
travailler plutôt que de remettre en
cause certains acteurs privés parce que
ils n'en sont pas dans la doxa dominante
des médias Valentino Berti il y a une
Inter importante aujourd'hui du Figaro
d'ailleurs Arnaud Lagardère a rencontré
les journalistes du JDD et cette phrase
je ne choisis pas Geoffroy le jeune dans
le but de changer la ligne éditoriale
mais bien évidemment le JDD doit aussi
savoir s'adapter aux ébulations du monde
qu'est-ce que vous en avez pensé moi
j'ai pas de de point de vue avoir sur la
ligne éditoriale du JG puisque je n'en
suis pas journaliste et donc c'est pas à
moi de la fixer en revanche je pense
qu'il ne s'agit pas dans ce débat d'un
débat gauche-droite en fait en réalité
il s'agit d'un débat qui dépasse tous
les clivages et on l'a vu dans les
questions à l'Assemblée nationale
il est question d'un droit à
l'information
dont tous les citoyens et citoyens ont
besoin et comment savoir que Geoffroy le
jeune sera un directeur de la rédaction
imperméable à une influence extérieure
lorsqu'on sait que Geoffroy le jeune a
fait la campagne d'Éric Zemmour s'en est
déclaré proche est un ami
de Marion maréchal qui soit de droite ou
de gauche là n'est pas la question la
question c'est que là on est face à un
problème de gouvernance des médias et
pas d'une supposer neutralité et puis
dans le cas précis de Geoffroy Lejeune
oui le
l'hebdomadaire dont il était le
directeur de la rédaction est un
hebdomadaire qui véhicule des idées
d'extrême droite et à titre personnel je
pense que l'extrême droite ce n'est pas
la même chose que un parti de droite de
gauche ou du centre alors Boris Vallot
votre avis vous savez ce que certains
disent c'est pas exactement votre
argumentation monsieur dufilipo mais on
a beaucoup entendu c'est son argent
après tout Vincent Bolloré il fait ce
qu'il veut avec il y a d'autres
quotidiens didopinion comme libération
marquée à gauche il y a 40% des lecteurs
aujourd'hui qui ont voté Marine Le Pen
au deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle donc il faut bien leur
parler ça fait partie du pluralisme
qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ça
il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs sujets
d'abord l'information c'est pas une
marchandise comme les autres voilà on
peut même dire à certains égards que
c'est un bien public et que la
République au fond l'histoire de la
République se confond avec celle de la
liberté de la presse depuis 1881 1944 un
certain nombre de grands rendez-vous
pour s'assurer de du pluralisme de la
presse de la liberté de l'information et
de la lutte contre la concentration des
médias et il y a évidemment il y a
dépendamment du cas d'espèce il y a un
certain nombre de principes qui sont des
principes démocratiques républicains et
qui ne se négocie pas on parle de de
Monsieur de Monsieur Lejeune évidemment
c'est une politique est à
l'opposé de ce que je défends et par
ailleurs il y a les trois présents que
vous avez évoqué iTélé se transformant
en cnews avec la violence que l'on sait
c'est pas monsieur Bolloré il fait pas
des affaires il fait le ménage il l'a
fait aussi à Europe 1 il l'a fait à
Paris Match pour en réalité
vous allez dire allez contre la ligne
éditoriale qui est en place elle est
contre les journalistes qui revendiquent
leur indépendance et leur droit à une
information
à une information libre pour imposer en
réalité une ligne qui est une ligne
idéologique
de la presse c'est d'abord lutter contre
la concentration des médias il y a 11
personnes qui possèdent je crois 60% des
titres en France ça pose d'évidence un
problème il y a l'indépendance des
rédactions bah elle est manifestement
contestée par la possibilité de ceux qui
sont nommés comme directeur de la
rédaction d'influer on a vu dans quelles
conditions Nicolas Barré finalement en
quelques minutes c'est retrouver
débarqué
aux échos mais il y a par ailleurs il y
a par ailleurs d'autres modèles le monde
les échos d'une certaine manière même si
on voit que c'est au moment de la
nomination mais pour le moment de la de
la de la démission d'office que ça
fonctionne mais où ce sont les
journalistes
qui approuve la nomination du directeur
de la rédaction c'est une question
d'indépendance c'est une question de
c'est une question de liberté à la
limite si le JDD aux deux tiers devait
approuver la nomination de le jeûne bon
bah on dirait ben écoutez voilà échange
la deuxième fois depuis 75 ans qu'il n'y
a pas de sortie du JDD c'est qu'il se
passe quelque chose de grave alors
Alexis lévrier c'est vrai que il y a
certains journaux qui ont réussi à
négocier des règles différentes et ça
interroge pourquoi certains diarrivent
d'autres non je le disais il y a le
monde il y a les échos notamment
libération aussi à des charts éthiques
comment comment expliquer cette
différence finalement Mediapart à un
modèle économique aussi très spécifique
très indépendant Médiapart est une belle
exception parce que Mediapart est
totalement indépendant il y a très très
peu de titres très peu de médias qui le
sont aujourd'hui en France et ça demande
vraiment beaucoup d'efforts la
construction d'une identité d'une marque
tout le monde ne peut pas arriver à ce
modèle là le monde avait aussi une
histoire très forte quand il a perdu son
indépendance en 2010 il a réussi à la
maintenir et la réussite à limiter
l'arrivée de certains acteurs comme
Daniel crétinsky récemment mais parce
que c'est le monde parce que la société
des rédacteurs du monde est extrêmement
puissante et qu'elle parvient à empêcher
l'arrivée de certains acteurs et c'est
l'attitude après des actionnaires Xavier
Niel
et relativement respectueux de
l'indépendance de ces rédactions le
monde a pu travailler sur l'affaire
Benalla révéler le rôle de Xavier Agnel
dans le dans cette affaire ou
l'indirecte mais il a fait connaître les
marchands
l'un des trois actionnaires le principe
le primaire du monde c'est le problème
de Bolloré il est sur un système un peu
proche de celui de repartemurdoch
c'est-à-dire qu'il a il mène une
croisette biologique vous parlez de doxa
dans les médias il y a pas de doxa dans
les médias dans l'histoire des médias
français il y a toujours eu un
pluralisme mais lui reste de ça une
croisade idéologique ça c'est des mots
très fort il ne respecte pas interne
c'est bien ce qu'on voit en ce moment
avant de parler du pluralisme à
l'échelle il faut pas le croire
mique bien sûr il veut imp
oser des idées politiques il le fait et
ce modèle il nous ramène en fait on n'a
pas connu en France depuis la Deuxième
Guerre mondiale c'est-à-dire que les
empires médiatiques qui mènent une
croisade sur des idées racistes des
xénophobes on l'a vécu dans les années
20 avec quelqu'un comme François Coty
qui avait racheté le Figaro qui avait
racheté le Gaulois
qui s'appelait l'Ami du peuple qui a
tirait à plus d'un million d'exemplaires
et qu'elle contribué à la diffusion de
ces idées là ce modèle là il s'est
arrêté justement évoquer la date de 1944
on a on a rendu possible la vitalité
démocratique des médias et on a tenu ça
veut dire que les médias d'extrême
droite ont disparu minute attiré à des
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires mais
c'était pas un média mainstream il y
avait une espèce de de de protection à
l'égard de ces médias-là qui est en
train de disparaître et il faut regarder
ce qui se passe avec la Commission
européenne en ce moment la Commission
européenne je trouve est beaucoup plus
active que ne le sont les pouvoirs
publics français et elle a vu les
dangers de monopole dans l'édition
Bolloré a racheté Lagardère d'enca
racheté il avait le numéro 2 non je
parle de l'édition mais il va se
débarrasser d'éditifs et il a un risque
de monopole sur la presse people qui a
dénoncé la Commission européenne et que
ne veulent pas avoir les pouvoirs
publics en France puisque par image est
considéré comme de manière de politique
d'information politique et générale
alors qu'il y a une partie people dans
Paris Match et que tout le monde le sait
bien et la Commission européenne va
imposer à Vincent Bolloré de vendre
certainement gala puisqu'il a aussi
voici avec le rachat de prismac
finalement c'est pas les 27 que cette
question de la concentration est pas
forcément ici à l'Assemblée Valentine
Oberti monsieur dit Philippot et ensuite
on va aller sur la scène du Théâtre
Libre où nous attend Marco pommier en
direct simplement pour rebondir sur ce
que dit Alexis lévrier c'est pas qu'on
pense que Vincent Bolloré a un dessin
idéologique c'est qu'il le dit lui-même
en réalité Vincent Boré Bolloré a dit je
me sers de mes médias pour mener mon
combat civilisationnel dont acte il le
dit il reconnaît lui-même avoir fait
venir Éric Zemmour sur cnews alors il
dit que c'est parce que Eric Zemmour est
une machine à cash on va dire mais voilà
donc il a il a il a il a agi dans les
médias qu'il a commencé à contrôler je
rappelle qu'il a aussi fait venir la
tête du service politique de repas c'est
pas c'est pas rien un service politique
dans une radio comme Europe 1 Louis de
ragnelle qui était journaliste à Valeurs
Actuelles si vous voulez le puzzle se
constitue de l'ingérence de Vincent
Bolloré dans les rédactions se constitue
assez facilement à l'épreuve des faits
c'est vrai qu'il y a un système Bolloré
fabiendy Philippot c'est c'est toujours
il y a un autoritarisme en gros vous
êtes dans la ligne vous restez vous
prenez un chèque il faut le dire très
clairement vous partez et et c'est assez
assumé si les chaînes soyons très clairs
si les chaînes qui la reprise ou les
différents médias rencontre un certain
succès en ayant pris l'orientation
éditoriale qui a été la leur c'est qu'il
y avait une attente de la part du public
ou certaines ou alors certaines choses
qu'il ne retrouvaient pas ailleurs je
crois qu'il y a un reproche qu'on ne
peut pas faire comme ça de but en blanc
le connaît pas à Monsieur Lagardère à
Monsieur Bolloré vous vous dites
directement raciste xénophobe c'est des
mots qui sont quand même très très forts
et vous savez vous l'avez dit
moi je ne l'ai pas dit que le pluralisme
était remis en question par la gauche et
je dis toujours ce qui est important
c'est ce qu'on dit c'est pas les gens
avec lesquels on échange et donc moi je
parle aussi bien des médias comme
libération l'humanité dont je sais que
la manière dont vont être repris les
propos que je tiens ne seront pas
forcément pris sous le meilleur angle
mais c'est le jeu de la démocratie il y
a pas de souci je vais vous dire la
seule chose qui me préoccupe vraiment
dans cette histoire on peut parler
d'ingérence politique on peut parler de
remise en cause la liberté de la presse
c'est le fait que la ministre de la
Culture elle-même Vienne porter un
jugement de valeur sur la nomination
à la tête
c'est une erreur une faute grave de la
mort
ce qu'il veut tant qu'il respecte la loi
mais pour nos valeurs républicaines
comment ne pas l'armée si quelqu'un est
trop à droite ça remet en cause les
valeurs républicaines elle n'aurait
jamais jamais dit la même chose encore
une fois une personne plutôt étiqueté à
à gauche mais est-ce qu'elle remet pas
un peu en cause l'indépendance
de notre cadre juridique dont elle
mesure manifestement les carences
puisqu’elle permet la concentration des
médias les atteintes au plus réalise et
concentré et elle parle d'orientation
des rédactions quand vous avez tout
votre rédaction elle ne s'oppose à vous
qui s'opposent à vous c'est qu'il y a
une question d'indépendance elle est
posée bien sûr elle ne peut pas poser
cette question-là parce que en charge en
changement de valeur et d'ailleurs elle
fait elle-même la part des choses elle
voit bien qu'elle est à la limite de
l'alignement
c'est le pouvoir politique et donc voilà
la question de de ce tweet peut être
discuté mais c'est pas notre sujet un
mot là-dessus puis on va on va partir en
direct au théâtre découvrir que la
ministre de la Culture fait de la
politique je suis quand même assez
étonné au fond elle n'est pas directrice
générale
de la culture en attendant 8 anciens
directeurs du JDD soutiennent les
grévistes qui sont réunis ce soir au
Théâtre Libre à Paris je le disais à
l'initiative de Reporters sans
frontières ou vous trouvez Marco pommier
ce soir alors
qui est présent autour de vous et quel
est l'état d'esprit des grévistes ce
soir
bah écoutez Myriam moi je me trouve dans
l'entrée du théâtre libre juste derrière
moi juste derrière ses portes il est
actuellement un millier de personnes
beaucoup de journalistes forcément on a
pu apercevoir par exemple Edwy Plenel de
Mediapart ou encore les tutorialistes
Bruno jeudi mais il y a aussi beaucoup
de politiques l'ancien candidat à la
présidentielle Yannick Jadot Eric
Coquerel pour les insoumis on a vu
également Sophie Binet secrétaire
général de la CGT et puis des
personnalités issues du monde de la
culture comme Jean-Marc Dumontet
producteur de théâtre moi je me trouve
avec Emmanuel Sophie journaliste au
service politique du Journal du Dimanche
Emmanuel Sophie bonsoir vous avez
rencontré ce matin le propriétaire du
JDD Arnaud Lagardère et vous n'êtes pas
rassuré pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il vous a
dit on n'est pas rassuré parce qu'en
fait nous avions une demande c'est à
dire que que l'arrivée de Geoffroy
Lejeune donc ancien directeur de la
rédaction de valeurs actuelles ne
viennent pas la tête de notre journal
fin du JDD pour le moment voilà Arnaud
Lagardère a estimé que c'était sa
décision
personnel il nous a bien précisé c'était
pas une décision de Vincent Bolloré donc
il va être le nouveau propriétaire du de
la garder à median news mais que c'était
sa décision à lui et nous a dit que le
JDD ne serait ne sera jamais valeur
actuelle mais voyez ce sont des
déclarations des intentions pour le
moment nous on a aucune gorge garantie
oui il dit qu'il ne veut pas changer la
ligne éditoriale du JDD vous le faites
pas confiance quand il vous dit ça
pour le moment tous les cas on n'a pas
de garantie nous permet nous permettant
en fait de pouvoir lui accorder ce
crédit là et c'est vrai que pour à
l'avenir on a besoin de savoir si on va
pouvoir travailler en toute indépendance
en fait vous voyez sachant c'est un
profil assez clivant pour nous c'est
clairement une ligne rouge qui a été
franchie dans cette nomination et en
fait à la différence d'autres d'autres
conflits qui malheureusement ont déjà eu
lieu quand Vincent Bolloré s'étant
emparé de média puisque son ambition
c'est de créer un un grand groupe
médiatique la différence du conflit avec
télé où on en parle souvent on fait
souvent un peu la comparaison nous c'est
là c'est lié en fait à une nomination
une nomination d'un personnage d'un
journaliste qui est un journaliste de
parti pris qu'un journaliste d'opinion
qui est un journaliste militant qui a
militait pour la campagne d'Éric Zemmour
durant les présidentielles qui étaient
un proche de Marion maréchal ce sont
tout ça vous voyez des idées qui ne
correspondent absolument pas aux valeurs
du JDD quel est votre état d'esprit ce
soir c'est quoi la suite est-ce qu'il y
a un journal qui va sortir dimanche dans
les kiosques qu'est-ce que vous allez
reconduire la grève dès demain on a
remis voilà la grève effectivement en
vote pour encore 24 heures donc il y a
le site aussi qui est toujours bloqué on
parle beaucoup du papier mais aussi
quand même un site internet qui est
bloqué depuis presque une semaine ça
fait depuis jeudi dernier donc ça ça va
être la décision en assemblée générale
voilà parce qu'on est on n'a jamais été
aussi unis dans cette rédaction qui
porte à peu près une centaine de
journalistes en incluant la fabrication
secrétaire de rédaction et les
journalistes pigistes donc ça c'est la
décision en fait qui sera prise en a en
assemblée générale et vous pensez que
vous pouvez avoir gain de cause que je
vois le jeune ne va finalement pas
arriver au JD d j'ai envie de vous dire
un combat tant qu'il jusqu'au bout il
est pas perdu donc on espère en tous les
cas que ce qui nous arrive aujourd'hui
sera un électrochoc pour toutes les
radictions rédaction de France
c'est-à-dire qu'on est même contacté par
des rédactions européennes allemandes
italienne qui s'inquiète en fait de
cette de cette montée rampante d'idées
xénophobe qui sont pas les idées
véhiculés par le JDD merci beaucoup
Emmanuel Sophie puis Myriam juste
quelques secondes regardez dans l'entrée
du théâtre libre et bien on a placé une
caisse de grève ça permet à tous ceux
qui le souhaitent et bien de mettre de
l'argent pour soutenir les grévistes de
la rédaction du JDD merci beaucoup Marco
pommier un électrochoc voilà c'est ça
que ils veulent au fond qui se créent
aujourd'hui et vous êtes les
législateurs qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va
regarder la concentration des médias on
a on a préparé un petit infographie avec
avec la galaxie sont quoi une petite
dizaine les les grands capitaines
d'industrie qui possèdent les principaux
titres de presse en France Vincent
Bolloré
Arnaud François Pinault Daniel crétinsky
et Xavier Niel et Patrick Drahi pour
l'essentiel il y a des aides publiques
aujourd'hui
perçoivent le JDD par exemple alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce que c'est
pas un premier levier d'urgence alors ça
peut être un premier levier d'abord il
faut avoir conscience que ce problème de
la concentration des médias il est pas
seulement français voire européen il est
mondial aujourd'hui et il est évidemment
européen d'ailleurs la Commission
européenne s'est emparée de ce sujet
avec le média frimedom actes qui est
aujourd'hui en cours de discussion de
notre côté il y a déjà eu des évolutions
législatives je pense à la loi Bloch de
2016 qui garantissait un certain nombre
de protections quant à l'indépendance
des journalistes aujourd'hui il y a mais
ça n'a pas suffi
aujourd'hui pour laquelle une mission
d'évaluation a été mise en place par la
commission culture des affaires
culturelles et de l'éducation au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale qui est copilotée
par Isabelle roche président de la la
mission et puis monsieur et shanise pour
le Parti socialiste mission d'évaluation
qui va durer 6 mois et qui va faire le
point sur cette loi est-elle aujourd'hui
suffisante doit-elle évoluer doit-elle
être modifiée ça c'est un premier point
et puis le ministre Verance est exprimé
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée nationale en
réindiquant en réaffirmant ce qu'il
avait déjà dit en janvier à savoir la
nécessité de mettre en place des états
généraux de la presse de manière à voir
comment il faut faire évoluer qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire
évoluer qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
évoluer je rappelle que voilà l'argument
principal de la concentration des médias
c'est résister au Gafa aux géant du
numérique américain on avait vu ça au
moment de la fusion entre M6 et le
groupe TF1 qui n'a finalement pas eu
lieu mais c'était l'argument principal
Boris vallon
elle montre aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de limites même si elle a permis
un certain nombre de progrès il y a eu
l'année dernière au Sénat un rapport de
David et souligne sur la concentration
des médias c'était il y a un an
pas de conclusion qui en a été tirés par
avec des propositions concrètes de
séparer le pouvoir de l'actionnaire et
de l'éditorial avec ce fameux veto ça
n'a pas été appliqué je pense que nous
pouvons les gérer sur cette semaine
possibilité de ce véto nous pouvons
aussi légiférer sur les contreparties
aux aides à la presse moi je serai pas
d'avis de dire on voulait retire il faut
qu'il y ait des règles et qu'elle
s'applique à tous et que nous les ions
pour pour les mettre en place ça peut
être ce droit de veto conditionne
précisément les aides publiques et puis
on avait essayé de le faire le Conseil
d'État l'avait retoqué mais moi je pense
que quand on a été un média condamné par
exemple pour des propos racistes je
crois pas qu'on puisse bénéficier d'être
public
Fabienne Filippo se met en garde mes
collègues qui voudraient encore
une proposition concrète
vous savez le problème c'est que après
les républicains ici a besoin de vos
voix pour faire passer les textes
pas tout supprimer et souvent et bien ça
peut être le fait de la journée que je
veux dire c'est que le mieux est parfois
l'ennemi du bien allez j'y Ferrer encore
davantage vous pouvez accentuer le
phénomène qui déplace la consommation de
médias vers des vers des réseaux sociaux
qui va créer des difficultés il y a deux
choses que votre graphique ne montre pas
le premier c'est la comparaison de la
concentration des médias chez nous par
rapport à aux voisins aux voisins
étrangers et je crois qu'il y a des pays
où c'est quand même un peu plus
concentré fortement que chez que chez
nous et la deuxième chose on a jamais eu
autant de chaînes d'information que ces
dernières années elles se sont
multipliées et quand vous parlez de
concentration il y a aussi un autre une
autre chose qu'on ne voit pas regardez
la presse régionale là vous avez des
grands groupes qui de plus en plus et
bien aspire des journaux d'autres
régions et qui et là ça peut poser des
questions parce que ils ont des
pratiques parfois qui ne collent pas au
respect à la prise en considération la
mise en valeur de de certains de
certains territoires mais en tout cas
c'est pas aujourd'hui dans l'information
les médias nationaux pressent radio télé
qu'on a des problèmes de qu'on a des
problèmes de pluralisme et si nous on
vient taper dessus en légiférant plus
durement pour contraindre ces systèmes
qui sont en qui sont en place vous
verrez vous aurez d'autres acteurs
alternatifs qui se qui se qui se
développeront sous l'égide des réseaux
sociaux qui sont totalement hors de tout
contrôler parce que quand même ces
médias ils ont une différence avec les
autres quand vous écrivez quelque chose
dans un journal exemple de valeur
actuelle que vous avez montré le prouve
vous tombez sous le coup de la loi il
faut que ce soit sourcé il faut que ce
soit vérifié vous ne pouvez pas
different des sanctions si vous regardez
l'arcome et le CSA au regard de cnews il
y a beaucoup de sanctions mais ça prend
du temps et et
c'est toujours un peu en décalage avec
déjà des informations qui que à ce qu'on
soit pas capable de légiférer aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux et quand on y
raconte n'importe quoi on est aussi
capable de cela mais là franchement vous
essayez de poser des questions en termes
de gauche droite franchement je crois
j'ai pas perçu
spécifiquement un journal de gauche mais
le sujet est pas là le sujet c'est comme
républicain comme démocrate est-ce qu'on
est attaché au plus réalisme à la lutte
contre la contrecentration et la
dépendance des médias c'est la seule
question qui nous est posée le problème
c'est l'analyse qu'on fait ici c'est
est-ce que cette action pluralisme et
moi je vous dis que
ce débatta chef je vais vous donner à
chacun la parole pour donner vos
propositions c'est la concentration en
elle-même le problème ou ce sont les
émissions sur la ligne éditoriale sur le
poids dans le travail même de
l'information qui doit être indépendant
concentration il y a eu d'autres
périodes d'extrême concentration des
médias français le premier grand acteur
c'était la fin du 18e siècle Charles
Joseph Franco qui est il a plutôt fait
du bien au pluralisme il était
d'ailleurs très favorable aux idées des
Lumières donc ça parce que Gérardin au
19e siècle était un grand patron de
presse et c'est sous son égide que la
loi ni 1880 le problème ce sont les
hommes puisque l'organisation économique
le fait que c'est des capitaines
d'industrie comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure qui ont des intérêts autres que
les médias ne sont pas spécialisés dans
les médias Bolloré de ce point de vue là
il est plutôt inexception parce qu'il se
ressentent aujourd'hui sur les médias
mais au nom de cette croisade de
idéologie dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure et vous disiez qu'on les faire
trop la loi sur la concentration dans
les médias date de 86 on est contre le
paysage médiatique de 1986 par rapport à
aujourd'hui donc il est sans doute pas
moins pluriel aujourd'hui qu'en 86 il
faut revoir c'est tout
cette commission sénatoriale l'an
dernier mais à coucher de rien si ce
n'est proposition intéressante mais dans
la l'Assemblée nationale dans l'exécutif
ne s'est pas saisi Valentine auberti le
mot de la fin les gars femme et être
puissant encore qu'on puisse remettre ça
en question sur la façon dont on
structure les médias mais partons de ce
principe là n'empêche pas les médias
d'être un contre-pouvoir pour eux-mêmes
c'est-à-dire que les médias sont un
contre-pouvoir dans la société contre
pouvoir politique économique mais
des médias il faut des garde-fous il
faut des contre-pouvoirs avoir un
actionnaire n'empêche pas d'avoir des
garde-fous quelques propositions
il me semble ça n'a pas empêché la
chaîne de dériver vers une chaîne
d'opinion et pas d'information et c'est
là que je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous
Fabien dit Philippot
il faut réformer les aides publiques
pourquoi pas attribuer un critère
d'indépendance pour les pour les
attribués ces aides publics il faut
donner le pouvoir aux rédactions d'agir
en justice leur donner une personnalité
juridique pour leur permettre d'agir
lorsque il y a un manquement à la
déontologie de leur média pourquoi pas
publier la l'identité des actionnaires
directe et indirecte de média pour plus
de transparence et enfin bien évidemment
et c'est un modèle que nous éprouvons à
Mediapart permettre au directeur et
directrice de la rédaction d'être élu
par les journalistes et d'être
possiblement révoquer aussi et ben voilà
les propositions elles sont sur la table
on verra ce que vous en faites Messieurs
les Députés on s'arrête là merci d'être
venu débattre sur LCP vous restez avec
moi Boris Vallot dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis alors ce soir le regard
d'Isabelle Lasserre sur la reprise en
main ou pas d'ailleurs de Vladimir
Poutine après le putsch manqué d'evini
prigogi après le salé le sucré avec
Fanny guinoche qui nous dira si le
projet de loi sur le partage de la
valeur fera oublier la crise des
retraites et puis dans Bourbon Express
ce soir quel est le menu elle demande un
Gava et bien je vous parle du déjeuner
entre Nicolas Sarkozy et l'aile droite
du groupe Renaissance au menu gaspacho
et politique intérieure merci beaucoup
Elsa allez on parle de vous à présent
Boris Vallot et des socialistes à
l'assemblée que vous pilotez depuis un
an vous avez voté 14 % des projets de
loi du gouvernement on a calculé c'est
plus que la France insoumise mais c'est
moins que le rassemblement national les
socialistes à l'Assemblée à l'heure du
bilan regardez c'est dans l'invitation
Stéphanie des pierres on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Boris Vallot c'est
parce que vous dirigez le groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée désormais Harry
mais à la nupes après une carrière de
conseiller sous François Hollande vous
êtes élu député des Landes pour la
première fois en 2017 réélu en 2022 vous
devenez le chef de fil des socialistes à
l'Assemblée avec les 31 députés vous
jouez la carte de l'opposition
raisonnable le camp présidentiel ne
désespère pas d'obtenir vos voix parfois
ça marche sur les énergies renouvelables
et une dizaine de textes cette année
vous parvenez même à faire voter une de
vos propositions par la majorité la loi
pour réguler les influenceurs en
revanche pas de compromis sur le budget
pour marquer que vous êtes pleinement
dans l'opposition le compromis est une
méthode vous voudriez qu'elle soit une
reddition vous n'aimez les oppositions
que quand elles se présentent à vous la
corde au cou comme les Bourgeois de
Calais je vous le dis madame la Première
ministre nous avions espéré de vous et
vous nous avez désespéré à l'Assemblée
cette année les socialistes vous êtes
sur tous les champions de l'abstention
tout groupe politique confondu vous vous
êtes abstenus sur 45% des 22 textes les
plus importants de la session sur la
réforme des retraites en revanche c'est
clair Boris Vallot vous mener le combat
au côté de vos alliés c'est non à cette
réforme injuste brutale et nous nous
contestons la nécessité et l'urgence
s'il vous plaît dans l'hémicycle vos
députés essayent de se faire entendre à
côté des bruyants insoumis vous auriez
voulu plus de débats moins de chahut
vous tentez d'accélérer les discussions
pour arriver à débattre de l'article sur
les 64 ans alors que la France insoumise
a le pied sur le froid on sent que cette
stratégie vous agace mais vous retenez
beaucoup moi je commande pas la
stratégie je vous ai déjà je vous ai mis
ce qui était l'anneau chocolat au
printemps cependant vous ne mâchez plus
vos mots au moment de la réintégration
d'Adrien catteninze par les insoumis
c'est une faute politique une erreur
dites-vous un an après malgré les
désaccords malgré les tensions internes
au PS l'Alliance de gauche vit encore
alors Boris Vallot comment imaginez-vous
l'angueux de la nupesse
réponse Boris vallon l'avenir il est un
peu en péril quand même on est allés
ce qui s'est passé depuis un an on
arrive dans un hémicycle dans lequel il
n'y a pas de majorité absolue
c'est-à-dire que c'est un objet
institutionnel non identifié donc au
fond personne ne s'est bien coiffeur
voilà il y a pas de mode d'emploi on a
le cerveau de la 4e République dans le
corps de la 5e c'est dysfonctionnelle et
on l'a constaté plus souvent qu'un autre
qu'un autre tour on a l'extrême droite
dans l'hémicycle qui arrive en nombre
c'est pas quelque chose de banal la
question de notre rapport à l'extrême
droite et évidemment posée et a fortiori
quand on voit dans la majorité des gens
prêts à glisser des bulletins dans
l'urne pour désigner les vice-présidents
d'extrême droite il y a évidemment cette
inter-groupe de gauche avec des cultures
différentes des histoires qui a bien
marché
au début elle assemblée mais dont on
voit bien que aux européennes par
exemple et des accords sont trop forts
une chose assez simple
moi je regarde quels sont les acquis et
puis qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
sur les acquis c'était une gauche qui ne
se parlait pas qui ne se parlait plus
qui désespérait le peuple gauche qui
disait mais entendez-vous pas surtout
mais entendez-vous parlez-vous on se
parle on s'est vu depuis un an toutes
les semaines dans des réunions
d'intervaux il y a eu des séminaires on
se dit des choses parfois sur sur les
retraites par exemple vous avez beaucoup
bossé on se rend compte que vous êtes
dans un dans une alliance avec LFI qui
veut revenir au 60 ans vous vous restez
au 62 éventuellement continuer un peu la
réforme c'est quand même des gros
désaccords sur la méthode on a eu des
désaccords de méthode ce qu'il fallait
les voter ou non l'article satisfaire
choix qui n'était pas évident bon nous
on est un peu subi
nous devions aller au vote parce que le
mouvement social d'une certaine manière
le demandait on s'est dit les choses
mais on a fait partout en France y
compris dans des petites villes de très
très éloignés parce que c'est important
de porter la parole de la gauche on a
fait estrade avec toute la gauche et on
a dit que nous étions posés sur un
certain nombre de sujets qui relèvent de
la Justice de la défense des services
publics de la défense de l'hôpital du de
la justice fiscale taxation des
multinationales des super profils nous
avons des alliances et puis il nous
arrive d'avoir des désaccords par
exemple parce que quand on regarde les
sondages ça doit quand même vous faire
réfléchir les sondages liste à part il y
a un différencier de 10 points de plus
quasiment sur le fait
sur ce sujet comme sur beaucoup d'autres
le Parti socialiste lance des
conventions il y a une conventions sur
l'Europe qui va d'abord répondre à la
question qu'est-ce qu'on pense les
socialistes et en quoi des socialistes
français en Europe parmi les
sociaux-démocrates peuvent être utiles
aux françaises et aux Français c'est la
réponse ça la question à laquelle nous
devons d'abord ensuite nous constaterons
parce que les autres partis font la même
chose des accords et des désaccords oui
on a eu des désaccords sur par exemple
l'adhésion de la Suède et de
et de la Finlande à l'OTAN on a eu aussi
des différences de positionner
déclaration sur Vladimir Poutine sur la
question de l'Ukraine est-ce que nous
avons refusé dans débattre moi j'ai vu
sur la question de la loi de
programmation militaire sur les
questions de l'Ukraine j'ai vu des
députés écologistes socialistes insoumis
débattre ensemble pour voir quel était
nos points on ne faisait pas depuis des
années vous y croyez jusqu'en 2020
je dis que tous ceux qui ne feront pas
l'effort de considérer que la gauche au
fond qui fait 51% dans ce contour de
l'élection présidentielle elle est large
elle est large
que au fond personne n'est à lui seul un
puzzle tout entier mais une pièce d'un
puzzle que nous avons à construire et à
constituer c'est là que l'on peut
construire une forme d'espérance
d'alternance d'alternative parce que si
c'est les panneaux ça risque d'être
l'extrême droite et là je vais vous dire
c'est l'aventure et pas pour le meilleur
donc il faut que chacun ait conscience
de de cela et moi les invectives des uns
envers les autres ça me fatigue est-ce
que je suis d'accord surtout est-ce
qu'on est toujours d'accord avec les
écologistes avec les communistes
entre socialistes nous-mêmes non je vous
dis moi la réunion de groupe il y a des
fois c'est pas évident on se pose des
questions
et on l'a très bien noté ici à LCP
pendant le débat sur Air retraite
notamment sur la fameuse pension
minimale vous avez contribué à lever un
certain nombre de floues et
d'incertitude et en même temps vous êtes
les rois de l'abstention 45% c'est
beaucoup quand même est-ce que c'est pas
le signe d'un certain malaise au sein du
PS entre LFI d'un côté et le
gouvernement vous n'arrivez pas à
choisir non pas du tout je vais vous
dire il faut bien prendre en compte le
fait que quand on est une majorité
relative en fait on a vraiment trois
votes pour contre l'abstention et
l'abstention et des fois elle bloque un
texte des fois elle le bloque pas et on
essaye on essaie d'être dans la nuance
la responsabilité en tout cas on prend
ce type ce type de responsabilité dont
je crois pas je crois pas on est dans
une majorité relative vous évoquez
qu'elle pouvait être nos victoires alors
vous avez évoqué la question les
influenceurs des des influenceurs on a
fait une loi au fond qui était trans
partisane Arthur de Laporte c'est
illustré mon travail sur les meublés de
tourisme avec les écologistes et aussi
avec certains de la majorité on a
travaillé regardez on a fait passer
contre le gouvernement de la
nationalisation de DF avec la France
insoumise avec les commisses avec les
républicains il se passe quelque chose
dans un assemblée c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué mais moi j'ai envie de dire de
faire le pari de ce parlementarisme et
de dire on légifère et puis l'exécutif
il exécute voilà parce que moi j'ai pas
été élu pour faire la majorité qui
manque Emmanuel Macron
pas mal de réformes à vous soumettre
encore
je sais que vous avez pas ça mais ça
m'intéresse de vous entendre le
mouvement de Bernard Cazeneuve la
convention est une impasse ça c'est ce
qu'a dit à Olivier fort vous l'avez bien
connu Bernard Cazeneuve quand vous
travaillez avec François Hollande à
l'Elysée
risque de s'essouffler de ne pas mener
très loin donc moi je regarde tout ce
qui se passe avec intérêt dès lors qu'un
moment donné je me dis que le point
d'arrivée c'est le rassemblement le plus
large possible d'une gauche qui soit
capable
d'améliorer
on peut tout tout ça je suis pas sûr si
on est en soutien c'est une initiative
qui est personnelle et ce qu'à un moment
donné elle est capable d'être de
s'élargir j'en sais rien bon voilà vous
ne répondez pas on verra François Ruffin
est-ce que ça démarre
se démarque très clairement de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon vous intéresse mais c'est
Ruffin et pardon François Ruffin et est
un député et un personnage intéressant
il est intéressant dans sa façon de
faire le fait d'aller j'allais dire au
contact de des classes populaires de
devenir leur voix de leur donner des
visages à travers ces documentaires il a
inventé quelque chose en politique oui
ça t'intéressant et puis il y a des des
combats où je vois qu'on peut avoir des
convergences la place du travail la
place des des classes populaires donc
oui ça m'intéresse mais il y a des
choses qui m'intéressent partout moi
j'essaye de picorer si on est enfermé en
pensant qu'on a raison tout seul en
étant fini par avoir
les jeunes socialistes se rebellent un
peu vous avez vu
contre les éléphants ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui un jeune pour lui dire venez
au peste
n'est pas mort d'un mot pour terminer le
socialisme est une idée radicalement
neuve voilà
j'en sais rien on changera non vous
savez moi je suis pas c'est pas parce
qu'on ravale la façade qu'on qu'on a
déménagé oui donc il y a la fidélité à
ce qu'on est dans l'histoire et puis la
jeunesse est impétueuse très bien et ben
moi je crois qu'il faut l'écouter même
quand elle nous boite les fesses de
temps en temps parce qu'on va pas
résumer mais elle a eu des mots un peu
durs merci beaucoup Maurice une jeune
femme de talent pour ce tour d'horizon
on va continuer à vous entendre parce
que c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite au féminin pluriel ce soir
Isabelle Lasserre correspondante
diplomatique du Figaro Fanny guinochet
de France Info pour le décryptage echo
bienvenue à toutes les deux on commence
comme chaque soir vous le savez par
Bourbon Express c'est l'histoire du jour
à l'Assemblée ce soir elle nous est
racontée par Elsa dans bonsoir Elsa
bonsoir je vous raconte ce soir
l'histoire du déjeuner secret le plus
commenté de la journée celui entre
Nicolas Sarkozy et l'aile droite du
groupe Renaissance un déjeuner faut le
dire quasi public regardez le député
Damien LR passés chez Emmanuel Macron il
a tweeté une photo n'hésite pas à
qualifier ce moment le mot et lâché
d'exceptionnel on voit donc sur la photo
l'ancien président de la République
entouré d'une quinzaine de députés
Renaissance l'aile droite du groupe au
centre main croisé concentré l'ancien
chef de l'État était invité à
l'Assemblée nationale par Éric Woerth
son ancien ministre du Budget passée
chez Emmanuel Macron puis il y avait des
députés transfuges qui étaient aussi
chez les républicains qui ont changé de
maillot pour soutenir Emmanuel Macron
constance le grip Robin Reda ou encore
et bien Damien a très content en effet
quel était le menu de ce déjeuner
gaspacho volaille entremet à l'abricot
ça c'est pour le menu gastronomique pour
le menu politique et bien évidemment on
a essayé d'en savoir un peu plus sur ce
qu'il s'est dit autour de la table on a
interrogé les participants
racontez-nous qu'est-ce que vous vous
êtes dit
il m'appartient pas de dévoiler par le
menu tous que nous avons dit mais on a
eu des discussions
très informelles très amicale très
chaleureuse beaucoup d'affection
beaucoup d'attention aussi sur beaucoup
de sujets français européens
internationaux sur un accord entre la
droite et le gouvernement ça n'a
vraiment pas été au coeur de nos
discussions on a parlé des grands sujets
politiques du moment on aurait parlé de
tout sauf d'un accord entre la droite et
le gouvernement en art tenté notre
chance
est-ce que vous avez parlé on sait que
Nicolas Sarkozy le souhaite d'un accord
entre la droite et le gouvernement
on n'a pas évoqué formellement d'accord
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui cet
accord n'existe pas et vraisemblablement
ne peut pas exister de manière
contractuelle mais on a parlé de cette
main tendue qui est nécessaire de la
part de la majorité présidentielle pour
voter des textes pour faire avancer le
pays et pour adopter les solutions qui
sont celles qui sont nécessaires pour la
France et pour les Français ils
attendent un accord avec la droite
ils attendent qu'on défendent la liberté
ils attendent qu'on réforme le pays ils
attendent de l'autorité de l'ordre dans
le pays et vraisemblablement nous
pouvons trouver une coalition d'idées
une majorité d'idéal assemblées
nationales pour faire cela ce qu'on sait
Myriam c'est que et bien Nicolas Sarkozy
a appelé a vraiment tendre la main pas
juste tendre le doigt pour goûter la
température de l'eau il a dit que même
si elle restait fidèle à son parti pour
lui si on aime la France il faut t'aider
Emmanuel Macron et puis sur la première
ministre Elisabeth borne il a rappelé
aussi que sa nomination avait un peu
floué l'électorat de droite alors
qu'est-ce qu'on en pense du côté des
républicains et puis des autres députés
macronistes plus à gauche alors côté
républicain on a posé la question ce
matin au président du groupe les
républicains Olivier marlex le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il n'avait
pas forcément très envie de répondre
Nicolas Sarkozy déjeune à la question
avec des députés de l'aile droite du
groupe Renaissance qu'est-ce que cette
rencontre vous inspire Sarkozy des
jeunes des jeunes avec qui veut
je pense que voilà je pense qu'ils sont
juponnes essentiel de l'ancien
collaborateurs à lui
comme Madame legrippe voilà donc ça va
pas
n'y voyez pas de signes permanents un
député de droite me confie plus
franchement c'est nul ça prouve qu'il a
franchi le Rubicon on ne peut plus
considérer qu'il est dans notre famille
politique côté Renaissance cette fois sa
tique aussi un peu chez les macronistes
canal historiques ils comprennent pas
trop cette affichage c'est ridicule on
dira un fan club on n'a pas vocation à
devenir une UMP newlook vous le voyez
pour l'accord de gouvernement on en est
encore loin merci Elsa c'est incroyable
quand même Nicolas Sarkozy qui
avec des députés Macron c'est plutôt
distrait la réponse de marlex quand il
fait beau
on enchaîne avec vous Fanny vous vouliez
nous parler du projet de loi qui en
débat à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
partage de la valeur après la réforme
des retraites et bien c'est le texte qui
est censé nouer la grande réconciliation
avec les syndicats exactement c'est un
exercice de calinothérapie qui est menée
en bonne et due forme par le
gouvernement qui espère donc retisser
les liens après des mois de conflits
autour de la réforme des retraites alors
ce texte insiste bien le gouvernement
ça doit être la retranscription très
fidèle de l'accord qui a été signé entre
le patronat et les syndicats cet hiver
sur le sur le sujet
sauf la CGT il faut le préciser qu'il
n'a pas signé et le gouvernement va même
un cran plus loin puisqu'il met il
demande même au parlementaire de se
mettre dans la main des partenaires
sociaux puisque Olivier du socle propose
de soumettre à leurs approbations les
éventuels modifications qui seraient
faites à ce texte par les députés ce qui
voudrait dire que la démocratie sociale
passerait avant la démocratie
parlementaire c'est rarement le cas oui
c'est rarement le cas alors pourtant
c'est pas un texte consensuel et bien de
prime abord il pourrait être parce que
l'idée c'est de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux Français c'est de permettre
à aux salariés de bénéficier d'un
certain nombre de dispositifs notamment
les salariés des petites entreprises des
systèmes de participation
d'intéressement pour ses salariés des
PME on estime que rien un million et
salariés qui pourraient bénéficier de
façon quasi obligatoire deux c'est en
plus que ceux qui est en bénéficient
aujourd'hui de tous ces dispositifs mais
ce texte il renverse pas non plus la
table parce que la question est souvent
posée par la CGT capacité donc l'accord
c'est que le risque c'est qu'il y ait
une substitution de tous ces dispositifs
par rapport à de vraies augmentations de
salaire il y a la question des supers
profits aussi qui va s'inviter
effectivement en plus le texte ne
définit pas vraiment ce qui est un super
profit sera au parlementaire de le faire
c'est une question qui fait souvent
débat en France et puis qui soulève
aussi d'autres interrogations parce que
ce texte il prévoit que quand une
entreprise fait un super profit elle
redistribue obligatoirement à ses
salariés dans l'entreprise c'est
bénéfices or on pourrait se poser la
question quand on regarde le nombre
d'entreprises qui ont fait des supers
profits en France grâce à des supers
aides du gouvernement mais quoi qu'il en
coûte des milliards d'euros des versets
c'est
Eric et hier notamment qui posait la
question de l'OFCE cette économiste qui
disait qui dit est-ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas réfléchir plutôt à une
redistribution plus large pourquoi
finalement quand la société a permis à
ces sociétés ces entreprises de faire
des supers profits il ne faut que les
limiter au salariés des groupes de ses
firmes vous voyez pour tous ces sujets
pas sûr que ce texte vise réussi sa
rabibocher tout le monde merci beaucoup
en un mot oui non vous le votez
le débat n'est pas terminé mais d'abord
il serait pas inconvenant que les
parlementaires puissent légiférer et
améliorer améliorer ce texte on respecte
le le travail qui a été fait par
l'interprofession mais comme vous l'avez
dit ça épuise pas le sujet la question
des salaires n'est pas posée la question
du comment parler du partage de la
valeur la création de richesse sans
parler de des salaires sans parler de de
d'écart de rémunération dans
l'entreprise il y a beaucoup de sujets
qui ne sont pas épuisés et qui
évidemment devront être traitant le
débat commence on va suivre évidemment
on termine avec vous Isabelle Vladimir
Poutine a-t-il repris la main en Russie
à vos yeux on est quatre jours après
l'insurrection manquait de prégogène
alors c'est ce qu'il essaye de faire
visiblement il a exilé Prigogine en
Biélorussie ça y est il est arrivé
là-bas Vladimir Poutine essaye de
reprendre la main sur Wagner en avalant
en fait Wagner en Russie et en désarmant
en tout cas en retirant les chars de les
chars lourds de l'organisation de la
partie de l'organisation qui va suivre
privigogine en Biélorussie on peut
s'attendre visiblement à des purges à
une remise en ordre voire à une chasse
aux sorcières il est pas exclu Myriam
kacor terme le pouvoir de Vladimir
Poutine soit consolidé alors ça paraît
bizarre de dire ça aujourd'hui mais par
ailleurs l'histoire ne se répète pas
tout le temps mais en 1993 quand Boris
eltine pour mater une tentative de
putsch qui avait été fomenté au
Parlement contre
il avait fait tirer sur le Parlement il
avait envoyé ses tanks tirés sur le
Parlement il y avait eu 200 morts la
parenthèse démocratique de la Russie
c'était définitivement refermée mais la
popularité de Boris selfie n'avait été
renforce l'idée elle était renforcée il
pourrait peut-être se passer la même
chose il faudrait d'abord quand même
répondre à la question c'est à dire
après la décision catastrophique de
d'envahir l'Ukraine et puis
l'humiliation qui a été
infligée à Vladimir Poutine qui n'a pas
pu arrêter la colonne donc par trigogine
est-ce que Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui
a les moyens de serrer la vis très très
fort et de reprendre complètement en
main le système qui est affaibli ouais
restaurer son autorité avant tout le
régime peut s'effondrer ou pas ce n'est
pas impossible non plus parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se passent en
coulisse depuis vendredi soir il y a
énormément de zones d'ombre à ce que
Prigogine avait des soutiens au Kremlin
est-ce qu'il en fait a été servi est-ce
que en fait on s'est servi de lui pour
essayer de tester la solidité du système
quel est le contenu du véritable deal
qui a été passé entre Prigogine et
Poutine on ne sait rien encore
aujourd'hui on a juste l'impression que
le système se délite que le pouvoir de
Vladimir Poutine ça faiblit et qui
pourrait s'affaisser comme ça d'un seul
coup c'est vrai qu'on a l'image
aujourd'hui d'un président
qui est faible dans un pays où en fait
on ne supporte pas la faiblesse ou la
faiblesse et quelque chose qui est
totalement méprisé alors qu'est-ce que
vous imaginez comme conséquence comment
vous voyez la suite si Poutine se
maintient au pouvoir on va vers un
durcissement du régime et peut-être sans
doute même une nouvelle escalade en
Ukraine si Poutine tombe est obligé de
céder la place alors là il y a plein de
scénarios tous plus sombres les uns que
les autres parce que le seul qu'on peut
exclure est une transition démocratique
et alors parmi les scénarios noirs on a
une guerre des clans d'emilis qui
s'affrontent un chaos à l'intérieur de
de la Russie
plus des forces centrifuges dans le
Caucase alors c'est pas très positif
mais il y a quand même dans toutes dans
toute cette noirceur il y aurait dans
ces cas-là une lueur c'est que ce serait
bien pour les ukrainiens et ça
faciliterait voire même
une victoire de l'Ukraine et donc ça
réglerait en partie le problème merci
espérons que voilà ces derniers mots
advienne merci beaucoup on s'arrête là
merci à vous Boris Vallot merci les
affranchis à votre place demain la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale il y
a le brune Pivet pour une émission
spéciale un an au perchoir et oui déjà
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée
restez vous fidèle soirée documentaire
qui commence avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain
[Musique]